[Musik]
Deutschlands erste Außenministerin
Annalena
berbock für mich war das natürlich ein
absoluter Sprung ins kalte
Wasser die grüne Ministerin will eine
neue Außenpolitik Werte geleitet und
feministisch wir brauchen keine
belehrende und moralisierende
Außenpolitik darauf wartet niemand was
ich an ihr wirklich schätze sie
schwurbelt nicht nur so diplomatisch
rum als Kanzlerkandidatin belächelt als
Ministerin vom ersten Tag gefordert als
krisendiplomatin ich glaube dass in der
Frage der Ukraine und Russlandpolitik
Frau berbock mit dem Bundeskanzler einen
durchaus grundlegenden Dissenz hat der
Terrorangriff der Hamas auf Israel eine
Bewährungsprobe auch für
bbock
dieser Tag ist eine zesur zwei riesige
Krisen Ukraine und Nahost in denen sie
beide als Außenministerin gefragt ist
ich Zweifel immer wieder aber wer nicht
zweifelt der ist entweder ideologisch
verboht oder hat keine Selbstreflektion
Menschen die heute in der Politik sind
sind auch
[Musik]
getriebene Mensch berbock die
undiplomatis
[Musik]
Diplomatin September
2023 als wir annaalena berbock in einem
Berliner Kino zum Interview treffen ist
sie fast zwei Jahre im Amt rückblick auf
den Beginn der Ampelkoalition vor Krieg
Energiekrise und Inflation am Anfang
stehen große
Hoffnungen lang langes her ich kann mir
vorstellen was sie denken oder manche
andere denken Mensch damals hatten sie
noch so eine gute Stimmung wobei man ja
ehrlichkeitshalber sagen muss wir sehen
auch alle ganz schön müde aus es war
auch spät es war spät am Abend wo wir in
der Frühphase von unserer Ampelkoalition
gesagt haben Mensch lass uns doch
wirklich mal zu vier treffen und gucken
wie wir das gut auf den Weg bringen
können so haben die Spitzen von Grün und
FDP bereits erste Vorgespräche geführt
die Koalition aus FP Grünen und
derd ur na gut es war damals schon klar
dass also so ein Herz und eine Seele
natürlich versucht man das nach außen zu
vermitteln das war sicherlich auch
damals nicht so das war sofort klar dass
das
Bild für lange Zeit stehen bleiben würde
als sozusagen quasi Symbol dieser
Verhandlung und Symbol dieser Annäherung
zwischen Grünen und der FDP wo man ja
damals schon das Gefühl hatte kann das
wirklich
zusammenpassen abe der Bildung der
Bundesregierung ich schwöre es im
dezember 2021 übernimmt die grüne
Annalena berbock das Auswärtige Amt von
ihrem Vorgänger Heiko
ma nie zuvor hat sie ein Ministerium
geleitet jetzt ist sie die Chefin von
weltweit rund 230 Auslandsvertretungen
und über 12000
Mitarbeit fel ja eher auf dass er nicht
auffiel und Gabri ging sehr rustikal
durch diese Welt sehr breitbeinig also
da kommt dann eine für dortige
Verhältnisse relativ junge Frau und das
verändert natürlich etwas das macht
etwas auch mit den Mitarbeiterin
Mitarbeitern und lenkt ein anderes Bild
auf Deutschland bbocks Ansprüche an sich
und das Auswärtige Amt sind hoch mehr
für demokratische Werte einstehen
schneller reagieren häufiger Klartext
reden auch wenn dabei diplomatische
Gepflogenheiten über Bord
gehen sie hat ausgegeben die Maxime
undiplomatische Diplomatie sie hat all
ihre Botschafter und Botschafterinnen ja
angewiesen in den jeweiligen Ländern
auffälliger zu sein auch dagegen zu
halten also feministische Außenpolitik
sie hat Klima an sich gezogen fürs
auswertige Amt also internationale
klimaverhandlung und eben
das undiplomatische Auftreten das sind
das sind massive charakterveränderungen
für das Auswärtige Amt ja erstmal habe
ich dieser Koalition durchaus ein Kredit
gegeben speziell auch Frau berbock die
von der man sehen konnte sie geht mit
Freude und Engagement in dieses Amt
hinein und ich war auch gespannt wie
wird das jetzt in der Klimapolitik
sowohl national kombiniert mit
Wirtschaftspolitik und wie wird die
Klimapolitik im Auswärtigen Amt
Rückblick 2018 werden annaalena berbock
und Robert habbeck zum neuen Führungsduo
der Grünen gewählt er ist Minister in
Schleswig-Holstein sie noch ohne
wichtiges Amt eine Tatsache die sie
rhetorisch für sich zu nutzen
weiß das war sehr gut dass eine Frau
sich hinstellt auf die Bühne und sagt
wir wählen hier heute nicht nur die Frau
an Robert Seite sondern die neue
Bundesvorsitzende von Bündnis 9 die
Grünen damit ist der selbstbewusste Ton
der späteren Außenministerin gesetzt das
war ein ziemlich kluger damit hat schon
mal noch zusätzlich Stimmen gekriegt der
fotogra begleitet Annalena berbock schon
lange seit sie grünenchefin
wurde wenige Minuten nach der Wahl
schießt er Backstage sein erstes Foto
von
ihr ich habe an berbg von Anfang an als
sehr machtbewusste und sehr
konzentrierte Person erlebt die gut
vorbereitet und auch mit den Menschen
lange vorher spricht um Macht zu
organisieren berb ist ist nicht nur
machtbewusst sondern auch bestens in der
grünen Partei
vernetzt Robert also Robert Habeck hat
man so schön gesagt macht kommt vom
machen ich bin in der Politik um Dinge
zu verändern und deswegen ist es eben
auch Teil
dessen Dinge zu entscheiden Sie weiter
auszubauen das ist für mich der Sinn von
Politik ich glaube wenn sie keine
machtpolitikerin oder kein
Machtpolitiker sind dann kommen sie nie
dahin wo sie jetzt schon ist dann dann
schaffen sie es vielleicht zum
Gemeinderat für mich ist wichtig den Mut
zu haben auch sich hinterfragen zu
lassen das verändert einen selber aber
stößt vor allen Dingen Veränderung in
anderen Bereichen glaube ich erst an
libe analena bitte die Bühne gehört dir
2021 lässt sich bbock zur ersten
Kanzlerkandidatin der Grünen aufstellen
und zieht damit auch am kovorsitzenden
habck
vorbei das sind die letzten Sekunden
bevor sie auf die Bühne geht und bekannt
gegeben wird dass sie Kanzlerkandidatin
wird und was wirklich tüpisch ist dass
sie sich da total vergräbt in ihren Text
und sich mega konzentriert um genau das
Richtige zu sagen und noch mal genau an
Detail
geht derb gilt als fleißig immer gut
vorbereitet
detailversessen doch der Wahlkampf als
Kanzlerkandidat in der grünen Gerät zum
Disaster die Grünen waren damals stark
Umfragen dass es wirklich vorstellbar
gewesen wäre dass Sie oder der Kandidat
der Grünen der nächste Kanzler die
Kanzlerin ist und das hat sie verbockt
rückläufig auch die Zahl derer die Anna
Lena berbock als reif fürs Kanzleramt
ansehen die innerhalb eines Monats
rutscht berbock in den Umfragewerten von
43 auf
28%. die Pannen mehren sich einer
Kanzlerkandidatin unwürdig so heißt es
im Bundestag macht sie die soziale
Marktwirtschaft zu einer Erfindung der
SPD statt der CDU geminsamandelt in den
60ern die Sozialdemokraten die soziale
Marktwirtschaft auf dem Weg gebracht sie
muss einräumen über d Jahre lang
weihnachtszahlungen nicht an den
Bundestag gemeldet zu haben es gibt
merkwürdige Korrekturen an ihrem
Lebenslauf auf Wikipedia insgesamt
entsteht der Eindruck von
Unprofessionalität und Überforderung ich
hab sie dilettantisch warahgenommen sie
hat einfach dramatische Fehler gemacht
als
Kanzlerkandidatin die unnötig waren und
die die Grünen extrem viel gekostet
haben 2021 nimmt berbur ihr gerade
erschienenes Buch vom Markt nach
Vorwürfen sie habe Quellen nicht korrekt
gekennzeichnet also der Umgang mit den
Plagiats
Vorwürfen den fand ich ungeschickt
amateurhaft erst beleidigt und dann
unsuverän da dachte ich das wird nichts
mehr natürlich ist es gerade im
Wahlkampf so dass man weiß dass jeder
kleine Fehler eine eine Riesenwelle
schlägt und deswegen bestmöglich
vermieden werden müssen und zugleich
haben mich gerade die Erfahrung im
Wahlkampf
wieder auch ein Stück geprägt damit
umzugehen mit Gegenwind umzugehen
zu wissen was die inneren Stärken sind
auch zu wissen was die eigenen Schwächen
sind
deswegen wä rückblickend das eigentlich
mit die beste Vorbereitung auf das Amt
der Außenministerin sie hat sehr vieles
davon wieder repariert
und ihre Arbeit als Außenministerin ist
da natürlich extrem
hilfreich eine robuste zielstrebige
Kämpferin so sieht sich die ehemalige
Leistungssportlerin Annalena berbock
selbst Dorothe Christlieb kennt die
junge Anna Lena aus
Kindheitstagen von 1987 an trainierte
sie das Mädchen aus Hannover über 10
Jahre lang im Trampolin springen wenn
ich an Anna Lena so in der
Pubertätsphase denke 13 14 gab es
durchaus auch Äußerungen sehr bestimmte
und wenn etwas nicht passte oder etwas
nicht funktionierte hat sie das aber
offen kommuniziert wir haben darüber
gesprochen und hatten insofern gar kein
Problem und das hat sich sehr bewährt
dass man auf kommuniziert und dass man
akzeptiert dass andere auch mal eine
andere Meinung hat als man
selbst dann habe ich mir vor der einen
Deutschen Meisterschaft da war ich noch
ganz schön jung ich glaube 11 oder
12 Knöchel gebrochen und zwar als
Trümmerbruch und ich kam heulend ins
Krankenhaus und der Arzt meinte so also
Mädel jetzt reiß dich mal zusammen so
doll kannst ja gar nicht weh tun und
dann ich habe gesagt es tut auch
überhaupt nicht weh aber ich wollte
Deutsche Meisterin werden nächste Woche
sind die Deutschen Meisterschaften und
so auch mit absoluter Frustration
Niederlagen umzugehen und dann doch
irgendwie wieder ein Anreiz zu haben
halbes Jahr später wieder voll zu
trainieren ich glaube es hat mich für
harte Zeiten in der Politik auch ganz
gut
vorbereitet wenige Monate nach
Amtseinführung trifft der Idealismus der
Außenministerin auf die harte
Wirklichkeit es hätte eine ganz andere
deutsche Außenpolitik und damit auch
eine wahrscheinlich andere
Außenministerin gegeben hätte es diesen
russischen Angriffskrieg nicht
gegeben Antrittsbesuch in Kiev berburck
legt Blumen nieder für die Opfer der
maidanproteste zur gleichen Zeit stehen
100.000 russische Soldaten an der Grenze
zur Ukraine noch wollen die wenigsten
daran glauben dass Russland wirklich
angreifen
könnte Waffenlieferungen lehnt die grüne
Ministerin ab auch unter Berufung auf
den Zweiten
Weltkrieg die Haltung der deutschen
Bundesregierung mit Blick auf
Waffenlieferung und zwar mit Blick auf
eine restriktive Rüstungsexportpolitik
sie ist auch in unserer Geschichte
begründet also hilfsverweigerung heute
wegen Verbrechen der Vergangenheit das
fand ich nie plausibel aber das jetzt ja
auch nicht der Punkt sie hat durch den
Krieg infolge des Krieges dann sehr
schnell diese Position richtigerweise
revidiert und ich finde das immer das
Wichtigste dass Politiker eben auch
zeigen können
dass sie ihre Position ihre Haltung auch
grundlegend korrigieren bevor der
russische Angriffskrieg stattgefunden
hat war Deutschland in der
Verhandlungsposition dass man mit
Russland und der Ukraine eigentlich
verhandeln sollte dass es nicht zu einem
russischen Angriff kommt in dem Moment
war meine Haltung wenn Deutschland jetzt
aktiv Waffen liefern würde würde
Russland sofort sagen ich dachte ihr
wolltet mit uns verhandeln es vielleicht
sogar als Grund Nutzen zu sagen wir
mussten ja angreifen weil unsere
verhandlungs äh Gastgeber die liefern
jetzt ja Waffen deswegen habe ich ein
paar Wochen vor dem russischen
Angriffskrieg noch im Deutschen
Bundestag gesagt in diesem Moment ist
nicht der richtige Moment aber es kann
sein dass wir unsere Position um 180°
ändern müssen aber das kann man nur
einmal tun das können wir nicht jeden
Tag aufs Neue tun berbock reist nach
Moskau um ihren russischen Amtskollegen
lavrov zu treffen es ist ihr erster
großer Test auf internationalem
Parkett da war sie noch gar nicht lange
aus Ministerin ähm dass sie dahingeht
und dass sie klar ihre Meinung sagt und
dass lavrov nicht durchkommt mit
irgendwelchen Tricks die er versucht hat
anzuwenden das ist mutig der Besuch in
Moskau war natürlich sehr sehr gut
vorbereitet weil der russische
Außenminister seit gefühlt Ewigkeiten im
Amt ist und Ermer versucht die gegenüber
zu testen aufs Glatteis zu führen im
Zweifel über Städte zu reden gar nicht
in Russland liegen um zu fragen ob das
eigentlich russisches Gebiet ist oder
nicht russisches Gebiet ist sie hat dann
ja auch eine ziemliche Schlagfertigkeit
bewiesen weil lavrov sie das war ein
Mittagessen dann quasi zu einem Vodka
eingeladen hat und sie diesen Vodka
nicht trinken wollte und dann muss er so
eine Bemerkung gemacht haben nach dem
Motto gehört sich so oder hab dich nicht
so und dann hat sie gesagt dass sie
schon vor Jahren in Moskau gewesen sei
und man ihr gesagt hat wenn du nicht
trinkst dann wird aus dir nie eine
wichtige Politik und sehen Sie jetzt bin
ich deutsche Außenministerin und wenn
das jetzt hier ein Härtetest sein soll
ich habe zwei Kinder zur Welt gebracht
das ist schon also da glaube ich ruht
sie in sich selbst und weiß genau was
sie kann und wen sie daagegenüber hat
für mich war eher wichtig und da konnte
ich halt gut auf mein Haus vertrauen
dass wir wissen auf welchen Themen
werden Sie wahrscheinlich drauf
rumreiten und dieses vorführen jemand
anderes vorführen was es halt vorher auf
Pressekonferenzen schon gegeben hat
darauf vorbereitet zu sein und sich
mental davon nicht kürre machen zu
lassen ja und ein Herr lavrov ist
natürlich der schwitzt ja die
Männlichkeit aus und dann steht Frau
berbock daneben und dann begegnen sich
in jeder Form zwei
unterschiedliche Symbole
über zwei Stunden dauert das Treffen ein
Ergebnis gibt es nicht auf der
anschließenden Pressekonferenz wird die
deutsche Außenministerin dafür
ungewöhnlich
deutlich den Despoten vor Augen zu
führen dass eine mutige Frau ist die die
Themen auch mal anspricht
das finde ich richtig und die die ihr
das vorwerfen und ihr moralisieren
vorwerfen die glaube ich wissen nicht
was für Dramen sich in dieser Welt
abspielen und wie andere Menschen leben
in welcher Armut und gefoltert
und ja also ich finde das okay in den
letzten Wochen haben sich mehr als
100.000 russische Soldaten mit Panzern
und Geschützen in der Nähe der Ukraine
versammelt
ohne nachvollziehbaren Grund und es ist
schwer das nicht als Drohung zu
verstehen klare Worte die in Deutschland
gut
ankommen der russische Chefdiplomat
zeigt sich unbeeindruckt Russland bedroh
niemanden wir haben erklärt dass es
keine Eskalation gibt von der derzeit
westliche Politiker sprechen und wir
haben erläutert dass wir keinerlei
Forderungen akzeptieren können die die
Handlungen unserer Streitkräfte auf
unserem eigenen Boden
betreffen mit ihrem Auftritt verschafft
sich die neue Außenministerin Respekt
auch bei Kritikern in der
Opposition wenn man sich lavrov
vorstellt ein Zyniker der mit allen
Wassern gewaschen
ist und der bestimmt eine innere
Geringschätzung gegenüber der jungen
Frauen und als neue deutsche Auen
Ministerin dort hat nach einem
schwierigen Wahlkampf auch für Frau
berbock das war eine hohe
disziplinleistung im Februar 2022 läuft
die krisendiplomatie auf Hochturen
Russlands Truppenaufmarsch geht weiter
bbur reist erneut in die Ukraine diesmal
an die Frontlinie an der sich
Regierungstruppen und von Russland
unterstützte Separatisten gegenüber
stehen dass sie dann zum zweiten Mal
hinfährt und sich da an die kontaktlinie
begibt also das hätte man nicht machen
müssen das war von ihr natürlich ein
Zeichen der Solidarität mit der Ukraine
wahrscheinlich hat sie da auch schon
geahnt dass die Situation eskalieren
könnte eine grüne Ministerin mit
schusssicherer Weste im Krisengebiet 14
000 Menschen sind hier bereits
gestorben bbock zeigt sich tief
bewegt natürlich hat sie auch daran
gedacht welche Bilder das produziert
eine Außenministerin im übrigen die
erste seit Gründung des auswendigen Amts
vor 150
Jahren die sich dann mit Schutzweste und
Helm dorthin begibt und dann auch mit
die entsprechenden Fotos entstehen das
ist natürlich klar dass dieses Foto
überall gesendet
wird 16 Tage später greift Russland die
Ukraine an
Krieg in
Europa die Außenministerin muss sofort
handeln da brauchte ich in dem Moment
die besten Berater aus meinem Haus da
haben wir in Sekunden mit dem Kanzler
telefoniert z.B die Frage evakuieren wir
jetzt die deutsche Botschaft da konnte
man nicht erst drei Vermerke schreiben
wie das vielleicht noch ein halbes Jahr
früher bei Themen im Auswärtigen Amt
stattgefunden
hat der Krieg und seine Folgen Bestimmen
von nun an die deutsche auenp
dre Tage nach dem Überfall spricht der
Kanzler im
Bundestag wir erleben eine
Zeitenwende und das bedeutet die Welt
danach ist nicht mehr dieselbe wie die
Welt davor
bbock reist weiter nach New York zur UNO
dort sichert sie der Ukraine
Unterstützung zu und sie spricht den
russischen Außenminister direkt an
ihre Panzer bringen keinen Frieden ihre
Panzer bringen Zerstörung und
Tod und in Wahrheit missbrauchen sie
ihre Macht als ständiges Mitglied des
Sicherheitsrats her la sie können sich
selbst belügen aber uns täuschen Sie
nicht unsere Völker werden sie nicht
täuschen und auch ihr ees Volk werden
sie nicht täuschen der russische Krieg
STT für eine Ladies gentlen Russ war
Real in der Ukraine macht sich berbock
ein Bild von den russischen
Kriegsverbrechen in butscha und
irpin es ist ein
Wendepunkt die Ministerin einer
pazifistischen Partei setzt sich jetzt
energisch für Waffenlieferungen an die
Ukraine
ein Annalena berborg hat wenn sie im
Ukraine Krieg gelernt hat sicherlich
sehr viel schneller gelernt als es der
Kanzler getan hat mein Eindruck ist dass
Frau berburg wie übrigens fast alle
ampelpolitiker im Amt lernend sind und
zwar dramatisch schnell und massiv denn
schauen sich an wie die SPD wie die
Grünen zu Waffenlieferung wie das ganze
Land im Grunde zu Militarisierung
gestanden hat und plötzlich ist da der
Krieg in der Nachbarschaft und die
politische Haltung dazu hat sich
komplett verändern müssen setzt sich
dafür ein dass wir immer mehr Waffen
liefern und meint dass das vielleicht am
Ende den Frieden bringt aber die
Erklärung wie die Ukraine diesen Krieg
gewinnen soll wo ja überhaupt nichts
dafür spricht die Erklärung ist sie bis
jetzt schuldig geblieben Frau berbock
ist in in in in diesem grauenvollen
Angriff Russlands auf die Ukraine ein
Glück für Deutschland sie hat einen ganz
klaren Kompass sie hat von anf an gesagt
wir helfen solange wir können wir helfen
so gut wir können und ich weiß dass sie
das auch so meint doch als Diplomat
unterlaufen ihr Fehler als sie sich im
Europarat wegen verzögerter
Waffenlieferungen Kritik anhören muss
kontert sie auf Englisch denn wir führen
einen Krieg gegen Russland und nicht
gegeneinander Europa im Krieg gegen
Russland Worte die Ver Schlagzeilen
sorgen das ist natürlich ein Versprecher
der politische Auswirkung hat natürlich
hat sie hätte sie diesen Satz auch nicht
gesagt wenn Sie ihn nicht irgendwie auch
so gemeint hätte das schnell muss die
Aussage abgeschwächt werden die Nato und
Deutschland sind in diesem Angriffskrieg
Russlands gegen die Ukraine nicht
Kriegspartei wir unterstützen die
Ukraine aber wir sind nicht Kriegspartei
in dem Moment wo ich es ausgesprochen
habe auf Englisch habe ich da schon GT
oh das kann jetzt auch missverstanden
werden jeder im Raum hat aber verstanden
in dem Kontext wie ich das meinte also
im übertragenen Sinne aber natürlich
danach wenn es dann ausgekoppelt äh wird
ähm dann wird es anders wahrgenommen und
das ist so ein Beispiel wo der Kontext
halt eine wahnsinnig große Rolle
spielt BBS spontane Formulierungen
stehen im deutlichen Kontrast zum
Kommunikationsstil des
Bundeskanzlers wir erleben ja auch beim
Kanzler wie er seit langer Zeit versucht
zu verhindern zu sagen Russland muss
diesen Krieg verlieren er sagt immer nur
es darf nicht gewinnen er will Putin
eine
Ausflucht lassen dass er nicht als
absoluter Verlierer da steht und
insofern ist da jedes Wort wichtig und
wenn Frau berborg dann sagt wir sind im
Krieg dann ist das eine
massive Gefahr weil natürlich die NATO
nicht im Krieg ist wir sind nicht
Kriegsteilnehmer und so weiter also
insofern ist ist da im Moment jedes Wort
noch wichtiger denn je also es war ja
klar dass sie damit nicht Russland den
Krieg erklären wollte aber eine
Außenministerin muss doch ihre Worte so
wählen dass Sie dass solche
Missverständnisse nicht entstehen
können das hätte ich beim nächsten Mal
sicherlich anders formuliert weil
natürlich das was ich sagen wollte was
anderes war als das was dann bei vielen
angekommen ist also das hätte ich beim
nächsten Mal sicherlich anders
gemacht jenseits des Krieges werden
bbcks eigentliche Ideen für eine neue
Außenpolitik
erkennbar das war in Kolumbien und das
ist die äh Vizepräsidentin die mit dafür
gesorgt hat dass es das Friedensabkommen
von den ehemaligen Rebellen miteinander
gegeben hat da sieht man auch Feminismus
Frauenpolitik und Sicherheitspolitik
gehört eng zusammen die deutsche
Ministerin bekennt sich zu dem was im
Koalitionsvertrag feminist foreign
policy genannt wird zu deutsch
feministische
Außenpolitik erst war ich zögerlich weil
er triggert aber deswegen habe ich
gesagt ist ja genau richtig wir wollen
ja darüber reden was müssen wir noch tun
damit wir wirklich in einer gleich
berechtigten Gesellschaft leben was kann
Außenpolitik dazu beitragen in anderen
Ländern Gleichberechtigung zu
unterstützen und kein anderes Thema hat
in den letzten anderthalb Jahren neben
dem russlandkrieg
so viel Debatte entfacht auch hier in
Deutschland und das ist gut das ist ja
für sie etwas dass sie sagt wir müssen
von der Perspektive des Menschen aus
unsere Politik machen der Frau des
Kindes was auch den Männern nicht
schadet und nicht das Staatsinteresse in
Vordergrund
stellen
lässt sich mit der Perspektive
westlicher Werte die Welt verändern vor
allem für ihre feministische
Außenpolitik bekommt sie viel
krik wenn ich mit Mitarbeitern ihres
Hauses zusammentreffe frage ich einfach
mal was ist eigentlich eine
feministische Außenpolitik das löst bei
den Kollegen von ihnen Schweißtropfen
auf der Stirn aus wir sind sehr für eine
wertegeleitete und interessengeleit
auenpolitik aber wir brauch keine wir
brauch
keineehrende und moralisierende
Außenpolitik darauf wartet niemand auf
dieser Welt bbocks idealistischer
Anspruch wegt Widerspruch aber auch hohe
Erwartungen was mich tatsächlich daran
stört sind nicht die Begriffe sondern
dass ich das Gefühl habe dass da nichts
mit Leben gefüllt wird dass es zwar
marige Sprüche sind aber was folgt denn
daraus und setzen eine Strategie für
eine feministische Außenpolitik
auf und ich habe das Gefühl gerade auch
beima Außenpolitik sie nicht gewusst hat
dass es so zum Schwur kommen wird und
sie hat es ganz mit ihrer Person
verbunden als einen einen neuen Anspruch
ein neues großes Wort für eine neue
Politik und gleichzeitig findet im Iran
eine feministische Revolution statt und
wer findet erst gar keine Worte das ist
die deutsche Außenministerin die die
feministische Außenpolitik proklamiert
und dann kommt der praktische Testfall
und es passiert nichts
hat bbck ihre Prinzipien verraten oder
ist sie hier pragmatisch im Kalkül
gefolgt um Iran als wichtigen
Verhandlungspartner in der Region nicht
zu
brisieren erst Wochen später setzt sie
sich für Sanktionen ein dies Hinrichtung
die für diese Gewalt alles was jetzt
weltweit passiert momentan was die
Konflikte betrifft hat direkten Einfluss
auch auf unser Leben hier in Deutschland
und das ist für mich so das wo sich
einfach zeigt ob sie am
Ende als gute Außenministerin beurteilt
werden wird als jemand der auch ein
Unterschied gemacht hat gerade was ihre
Ansprüche betrifft gerade Frauen und
Mädchen betreffend oder eben
nicht Besuch im
Irak Krisen und Kriege erhöhen den
Migrationsdruck Hilfe vor Ort soll die
Menschen dazu bewegen im Land zu
bleiben nach dem Kampf die
Terrororganisation islamischer Staat ist
der Klimawandel jetzt das drängendste
Problem hier ist das humanitäre
Engagement Deutschlands besonders
gefragt in der Seenlandschaft südlich
von Basra wird das wasserknapp bbock
will sich bei einer einheimischen
Familie ein Bild
machen Mitarbeiter Journalisten Security
alle drängen sich auf engstem
Raum im Gespräch mit den Einheimischen
ruft auch deren Kinder herbei es
entsteht ein für sie typischer
Moment während draußen vor dem Zelt die
Mitarbeiter vom Protokoll nervös auf die
Uhr schauen weil später noch die
Heimreise nach Deutschland ansteht
spielt die Außenministerin mit den
Kindern im
Zelt da waren wir im Süden vom Irak auch
Grenze zum Iran rüber die leben nämlich
dort wo die Ölfelder des Irak sind das
heißt s leben eigentlich in einer total
reichen Region wo das Öl herausgeholt
wird sind aber bitterarm und deren
message obwohl die wahrscheinlich vom
Klimaschutz und Friday for future und
all das noch nie was gehört haben das
wichtigste was sie mir mitgeben wollten
hat am Ende
gesagt please remember bring water weil
das Wasser da zurückgeht wegen der
Klimakrise ihre Wasserbüffel von denen
sie leben sterben also der wichtigste
Auftrag von ihm war eigentlich auch der
der Klimaschutz und wieder das mit in
unsere internationalen Gespräche zuingen
auch das war Teil dieser Reise und
manchmal bedeutet das auch mit Kindern
ein kleines Holzspiel zu
[Applaus]
spielen immer wieder muss ich bärburg
den Vorwurf gefallen lassen sie setze
auf ihren Reisen die falschen
Prioritäten und zu sehr auf
Inszenierung es wäre glaube ich der
Gipfel des Zynismus wenn man jetzt bei
jedem öffentlichen Auftritt immer nur
die Inszenierung unterstellen würde ich
würde jetzt in solche Bilder auch nicht
zu viel reinlesen und ich würde auch
davon nicht irgendwie mein Urteil über
ihre Außenpolitik abhängig machen sie
nimmt diese Erfahrung als Frau und
Mutter nimmt sie mit in ihre Aufgabe und
sieht damit in der Welt auch andere
Dinge und die artikuliert sie und wenn
sie über das Leiden von Kindern spricht
dann nimmt man ihr das ab weil sie
kleine Kinder zu Hause hat wie viel Zeit
bleibt der Ministerin mit der eigenen
Familie
mir hilft es total dann nach Hause zu
kommen und wenn meine Kinder
Grundschulkinder da sagen Mama und wir
haben heute das in der Schule gemacht
vor einem Moment ist dann all das was
mir vielleicht im Kopf rum schwürt was
mich total belastet dann auch mal
einfach weg weil man ins Schwimmbad geht
was ganz anderes
macht auf dem Weg nach Peking begleitet
vom chinesischen
amtskollegeningong das Auswärtige Amt
bezeichnet China als Partner erber und
systemischen
Rivalen 2022 war das Land das 7b Jahr
infolge wichtigster Handelspartner
Deutschlands traditionell pflegt die
Bundesrepublik einen zurückhaltenden
Umgang mit den Herrschern in Peking
bbocks Werte geleitete Außenpolitik
steht hier besonders auf dem
Prüfstand ich Rei da nicht hin und denke
jetzt wollen wir mal richtig
diskutieren sondern Reise in jedes Land
zu schauen okay wo haben wir
Schnittmengen wo können wir ausloten
dass wir mehr gemeinsame Arbeit
Zusammenarbeit haben natürlich habe ich
großes Verständnis dafür dass jemand wie
Frau berborg sagt wir müssen sehr viel
stärker eine Werte geleitete
Außenpolitik betreiben ob das
funktioniert ist noch
offen für die chinesischen Diplomaten
ist die deutsche Außenministerin eine
Herausforderung insbesondere BB Hinweis
auf die
Menschenrechtslage es mit Sorge sehen
dass freieräume für
zivilgesellschaftliches Engagement in
China immer weiter schrumpfen und
Menschenrechte beschnitten werden der
chinesische Außenminister Konter
scharf unser Austausch sollte auf
Respekt und Gleichberechtigung beruhen
was China am wenigsten braucht sind
Lehrmeister aus dem
Westen deutschland ist ein Land ohne
Rohstoffe Deutschland ist eine
Handelsnation Deutschland ist darauf
angewiesen dass es vor allemel stand und
den exportierenden Unternehmen gut geht
insofern wäre Deutschland gut beraten
auch unter einer grünen Außenministerin
die Interessen der wichtigsten
Handelspartner des Landes nicht mit
Füßen zu treten und nicht allzu
moralisch belehrend aufzutreten das mag
auf dem grünen Parteitag gut ankommen
aber in Peking vielleicht nicht ganz so
sehr in der Pressekonferenz das war der
Fall in China hat der chinesische
Außenminister gesagt wir bräuchten jetzt
mal gemeinsame menschenrechtsreg weil es
gibt ja gar keine gemeinsamen
menschenrechtsregeln und da hatte ich
eigentlich nur drauf hingewiesen und
gesagt also aus meinem Verständnis haben
wir die universelle Erklärung der
Menschenrechte die ja auch China mit
unterzeichnet hat da haben da manche
gesagt ja jetzt streitet sie sich über
die Menschenrechte aber wenn ich dazu
geschwiegen hätte hätte das bei meinem
Gegenüber hätte das ja auch bei der
Öffentlichkeit in China doch etwas für
Verwunderung gesorgt dass ich
offensichtlich akzeptiere dass es keine
internationale Vereinbarung zu
Menschenrechten
gibt Diplomatie und Klartext an China
zeigt sich wie schwer das zu verbinden
ist in einem Interview fürs usfernsehen
bezeichnet berbur den chinesischen
Staatsschiff kurzerhand als
Diktator wenn Putin diesen Krieg gewinnt
was wäre das für ein Zeichen für alle
anderen Diktatoren auf der Welt wiei den
chinesischen
Präsidenten China reagiert empört
spricht von einer Verletzung der Würde
und in der Bemerkung BB eine
Provokation dass man mit mit Menschen
wie lavrov und Putin hart umgeht das
würde niemand bezweifeln ob im Falle von
China unserem größten
Handelspartner dass der richtige Umgang
ist dann dem Staatschef zu sagen du bist
ein
Diktator da kann man Fragezeichen setzen
Kritik gehört zum Geschäft ihr
Privatleben dagegen versucht berbock so
gut wie möglich AbZ Schotten nur selten
spricht sie über Mann und Kinder das ist
das härteste also das ist für mich
wirklich das härteste weil man ist fast
nie mehr Privatperson natürlich hat das
auch ein Einfluss auf die Kinder dass
ich ständig erkannt werde und dass sie
damit auch erfahren dass wenn wir
irgendwo sind und ich erkannt werde sie
damit im Umfeld auch erkannt werden und
das ist das ist wirklich das härteste
das ist auch der Preis würde ich
sagen Z Ehrlichkeit gehört ja auch man
hat durch Bekanntheit gewisse
Annehmlichkeiten aber das ist der Preis
den man meiner Sicht ein bisschen dafür
bezahlt
Öffentlichkeit und Opposition blicken
mit unter kritisch auf die vielen
Flugreisen der Grünen
Ministerin im Juni 2023 geht es mit
Arbeitsminister Hubertus Heil nach
Brasilien wio oft nutzt bärburg auch
diese Reise intensiv für Pressearbeit
hallo mit an Bord Journalisten aller
großen deutschen
Tageszeitungen wenn ich jetzt z.B
zurückkomme von so einer Reise rede ich
5 Minuten im Bundestag da kann ich nicht
über jede einzelne Station meiner Reise
reden deswegen nehmen wir Journalisten
mit die dann ja auch über das
regenwaldprojekt vor Ort schreiben und
damit in den deutschen Zeitung jetzt
nicht über die deutsche Außenministerin
schreiben sondern das was den Menschen
aus dem Anat zomas wichtig ist
hoffentlich auch in die deutsche Debatte
mit einbringen deswegen ja haben wir
immer viele Journalisten mit dabei in
der Hoffnung dass die Themen die wir
dort vor Ort sichtbar machen wollen dass
die auch in die deutsche
Medienöffentlichkeit transportiert
werden nicht für die Außenministerin
sondern für die Themen und das was wir
politisch voranbringen wollen
Hintergrundgespräch mit der Ministerin
Mitten überm Atlantik ein exklusiver
Gesprächskreis es gilt die Absprache
dass kein Journalist daraus zitieren
darf auch der Kameramann wird nach ein
paar Minuten aufgefordert den zu
verlassen genau nur Auftag dann bin ich
sofort
weg sie ist anders in den hinterung
Gesprächen sie ist
m sehr offen würde ich sagen man erfährt
wirklich auch etwas darüber wie sie
denkt warum sie bestimmte Positionen
vertritt warum sie bestimmte Termine
gemacht hat ihr Vorgänger Heiko Mar hat
wenig Hintergrundgespräche geführt da
hatte man immer das Gefühl der wollte
irgendwie unseren Fragen ausweichen oder
zumindest besonders besondere Freude hat
er daran nicht berbock merkt man an dass
sie das auch sucht und
will Ankunft in Brasilia seit 1960
Hauptstadt
Brasiliens hinter BBG liegen jetzt eine
stündige Flugreise politische Gespräche
und
pressestatements und die eigentliche
Arbeit wartet noch wieder muss sie in
einem schwierigen politischen Umfeld
agieren kurz nach den Präsidentenwahl
hatte es Anfang des Jahres hier Unruhen
gegeben in vielen hinterzimmerterminen
wird die Außenministerin politische
Gemeinsamkeiten und Differenzen
ausloten wenn ich irgendwo ans andere
Ende der Welt fliege dann Takten wir den
Tag durch von morgens bis abends tief in
die Nacht und klar braucht dafür eine
gewisse Fitness also mit wenig Schlaf
auszukommen ich glaube das wird dann
oftmals unterschätzt es ist eine der
Schlüsseldisziplinen für Politik
Diplomatie der kleinen
Schritte am anderen Ende des roten
Teppichs wartet die stellvertretende
Außenministerin
Brasiliens 26 Länder hat bbock allein in
den ersten 5 Monaten dieses Jahres
bereist also wenn sie mich jetzt fragen
würden was waren die letzten Reisen in
den letzten Monaten MSS ich schon
aufpassen dass überhaupt in das richtige
Jahr zu bringen also angesichts dessen
was in den letzten zwei Jahren war hat
das eine Taktung dass ich mich nicht an
jede einzelne Reise erinnern kann
natürlich wenn man fragt warst du schon
da weiß ich es noch aber ob das jetzt
vor zwei Monaten war oder vor 5 Monaten
war das muss ich dann noch mal stark
nachdenken auch wenn nur 45 Minuten Zeit
bleiben um miteinander zu sprechen in
der Diplomatie kann der persönliche
Kontakt entscheidend
sein später reist bbock weiter nach
Kolumbien und
Panama wir kommen jetzt gerade zurück äh
von einer ganzen Woche Reise dann ist es
nur noch der Sonntag Nachmittag muss man
EHRLICHKEIT sber sagen der da ist aber
dann zumindest an diesem Nachmittag zu
sagen all meinen Mitarbeit so meine
Handys sind jetzt aus für 5 Stunden wenn
die Welt brennen würde dann wissen Sie
welche Nummer Sie anrufen und dann bin
ich erreichbar aber ich gucke jetzt
nicht alle paar Minuten auf mein Handy
um zu gucken was passiert sondern dann
wenn weiter 30° draußen sind ja dann
fahre ich auch mit dem Rad mit den
Kindern zum See und bin dann in dem
Moment nur
Mutter
Februar
2022 Antrittsbesuch in
Israel dort gedenkt sie der von den
Nationalsozialisten ermordeten 6
Millionen
Juden die Außenministerin ringt
Umfassung als Mutter zweier Töchter
stockt mir der Atem wenn ich an die
Millionen jüdischer Kinder denke die
ermordet
wen Eltern
entrissen alle lassen voller Schmerz und
Angst vor dem
Ungewissen der Gedanke an den Schmerz
jedes einzelnen Kindes jeder einzelnen
Mutter jedes einzelnen Vaters ist kaum
zu
ertragen der Horror kommt im
morgenum Terroristen der
radikalislamischen Hamas überfallen
Israel ermorden und verschleppen wahlos
Menschen
der Angriff gilt dem jüdischen
Volk Israel ist verwundet wie nie
zuvor mein Eindruck ist dass Frau
berwock relativ schnell reagiert hat und
auch gute Reflexe hatte also sie war AR
schnell da sie hat volle Solidarität
erklärt sie hat aber gleichzeitig auch
was ja auch wichtig ist gesagt wir
werden weiter humanitäre Hilfe leisten
für
Gaza die Außenministerin trifft
Angehörige der Opfer der Terroranschläge
und zeigt sich ähnlich wie in der
Ukraine zutiefst
erschüttert das Frau berburg ihre
Gefühle zeigt glaube ich erhöht bei
vielen ihre
Glaubwürdigkeit möglicherweise auch bei
Gesprächspartnern es ist ein
ungewöhnlicher Ansatz für Diplomatie und
für Außenpolitik vielleicht müssen wir
uns daran
gewöhnen jetzt im narost ist sie sehr
viel stärker auf Linie mit dem Kanzler
das heißt da gibt's eine ganz hohe
außenpolitische Übereinstimmung und sie
haben beide eine größere Rolle als sie
möglicherweise gedacht haben ich sehe
das auf israelischer Seite dass genau
das viele als unsere Aufgabe jetzt sehen
dass wir diese Gesprächskanäle offen
halten dass wir mit dazu beitragen dass
es nicht zu einem Flächenbrand kommt die
Gefahr droh dass es eine zweite Front
gibt mit Blick auf das Westjordanland
eine dritte Front mit Blick auf den
Libanon wenn die hisbolla in diesen
Konflikte einsteigt dann droht aller
aller aller Allers schlimmstes und genau
daran müssen wir mitwirken dass wir das
verhindern ein klares Bekenntnis zur
parteiübergreifenden
krisendiplomatie Pragmatismus statt
Idealismus Annalena berbg steht
möglicherweise vor Herausforderungen die
noch kein Deutscher Chefdiplomat vor ihr
bewält
musste die Außenministerin ist mit
diesem Krieg in Nahost eine Managerin
einer noch erweiterten Zeitenwende wir
erleben ja dass die Welt sich völlig neu
formiert mit kriegen mit militärischen
Notwendigkeiten mit einem viel stärkeren
außenpolitischen und militärischen
Engagement der deutschen und genau das
muss sie mit
managen als sie das Amt angetreten ist
hat sie mit einem weißen Blattpapier
angefangen wenn ich in einem Job die
erste bin die erste Frau die sowas macht
habe ich keine Vergleiche mit Vorgängern
keiner wird sie mit Genger vergleichen
keiner wird sie mit Westerwelle
vergleichen keiner wird sie mit Heiko ma
vergleichen sondern sie hat die
Möglichkeit in Deutschland für
Deutschland Geschichte zu
schreiben
ich finde für mich dass das genau das
richtige Amt für mich ist als Annalen
berbock ob ich die richtige Auen
Ministerin bin zur richtigen Zeit das
müssen andere
beurteilen wie viel undiplomatisches am
Ende ihrer Amtszeit übrig sein wird kann
Annalena berbock nicht allein
bestimmen ihr Erfolg ist verknüpft mit
der neuen Rolle Deutschlands in einer
unruhigen
[Musik]
Welt